[Music]
the social
media savior yay verily i say unto you
there were influencers abiding in the
feed keeping watch over their followers
by night
and hello i came upon them and the glory
of my posts
shot
[Music]
freedom freedom [ __ ] freedom
which matters more the freedom to live
an authentic life or
the freedom to crush degenerates under
the heel of a jack boot
as a centrist i am undecided but the
important thing is
we are talking about it hi i'm jackie
jackson
host of the freedom report the political
talk show where we discuss important
issues
like mexicans how dangerous are they
muslims
can we stop them tonight we return once
again to the dangerous
transgender trend that is turning your
children into all manner of half and
halfs and in betweens
i mean look at this they're transiting
13 year olds now what's next
babies with breast implants it makes me
want to throw up
i live in constant fear and fear is what
freedom is all about
cut them music tonight my first guest is
tiffany tumbles
transgender makeup vlogger and
conservative opinion haver
and my second guest well what the hell
are you you're transgender
you're a man you're a woman you're an
attack helicopter
what's your deal well jackie jackson
my as you say deal is i don't like
society
forcing me into tiny little boxes
okay but are you a man or a woman just
tell me well why does it matter
why do you have to know maybe you should
examine why it is you feel the need
to fit everyone you meet into these
little categories
jackie jackson well can i at least
ask your name or is that now considered
cisgender imperialism
my name is baltimore baltimore what
baltimore maryland i'm sorry
your name is baltimore maryland it is
among
my names tiffany what do you make of
this
look jackie i'm gonna be completely real
with you i
am a transsexual that means i have a
very specific mental disorder called
gender dysphoria
i was born a boy but i have a female
brain because of a hormone imbalance in
the womb
this is a real psychiatric disorder that
is verified by science
and requires hormones and surgery for
treatment or else i literally cannot
function
it is not a fashion statement it is not
a trend it is not an easy way to feel
special and depressed
it is a very difficult condition to live
with
i'm dying inside okay so you're both
transsexuals then
now i am a transsexual that is not a
transsexual
that is a transtrender trans trender
what is that is that a gender no it's
not a gender a trans trender is a person
like
baltimore over here who puts on a dress
and puts glitter in his beard
and goes around telling people he's
transgender and complaining about
misgendering for oppression points
actually
it's they what i use they them pronouns
they go around collecting oppression
points as you can see
why do you say that tiffany tumbles have
i complained about oppression
so far it seems to me that it is you
who has been complaining about your
dysphoria
isn't it you who is collecting
oppression points
tiffany tumbles oh no i'm not i'm not
saying i'm oppressed
i'm saying i have dysphoria which is not
society's fault
it's in my brain i was diagnosed it's a
fact
it's real my pain is real and
my pain isn't real it's interesting that
you think that
well what pain are you talking about
people making fun of you because you
dressed like a circus act
interesting that you mentioned the
circus tiffany tumbles
don't you think we should examine why
society confines
gender variant people to the circus
you're not confined anywhere you choose
to dress like that
and why do you choose to dress the way
you dress
because i'm a woman so i'm dressed like
a woman hello
and i'm non-binary so i dress
non-conforming
why should i conceal who i am just to
appease
small-minded people well it's a free
country if you want to be a good of your
gender [ __ ] then go ahead
but don't go around telling people that
you're transgender
because it makes us all look like a
bunch of trendy freaks but aren't we
all freaks in the eyes of society
do you think you can purchase acceptance
through conformity
because that is not freedom tiffany
tumbles
that is simply adding another cell to
the prison
it's not about conforming it's about me
having an actual medical condition
you do not have a female brain you have
a fashion disaster
oh do they well tell me tiffany tumbles
when the doctor prescribed your hormones
did he
take a look at your brain then what of
course not
but you have seen a skin of your brain
yes
well no where are you going with this i
mean
if you've never seen your brain and the
doctor who diagnosed your gender
dysphoria didn't look at it then
tell me tiffany tumbles how do you
know that you have a female brain
oh [ __ ] that's a good point no it isn't
look
there's scientific studies can you
explain to me the difference
between a male brain and a female brain
are they different colors i'm not an
expert
but there's science showing that men and
women have brain differences
i see but your doctor never looked at
your brain
so how did he know that you have gender
dysphoria
well he asked me questions and i told
him about it
and you told him what exactly
that i experienced gender dysphoria so
would you agree then
that your gender dysphoria and therefore
your identity
is valid not because of any observed
facts about your brain but
because of your
feelings well congratulations attorney
frankenfurter
you backed me into a corner sure it's
because of my feelings
my feelings of gender dysphoria so tell
me
tiffany tumbles why is it that your
feelings about your gender are valid
but mine according to you are not
this burgeoning brick you guys let's
think about this
if i have never seen my brain
how do i know i even have a brain well
you probably don't girl
look baltimore i'm sure you have lots of
feelings about your
gender and if you feel cloud gender or
demi nebula or astroglide
or whatever tumblr [ __ ] passes
through your mind
then you do you girl or not girl
whatever the [ __ ] you are but i want to
make one thing very clear
i am nothing like you okay
my gender is not unicorns and glitter my
gender is a serious
psychiatric diagnosis that i wouldn't
wish on my worst enemy
no not even you my i'm really getting
under your skin
aren't i no well actually
yes to be honest you are you're getting
under my skin because it really
rattles my dysphoria that you're sitting
here claiming to represent the
transgender community
when in fact you're just making a
mockery of my pain
your pain you're in a lot of pain
aren't you tiffany tumbles well
i can sense the vibrations of your pain
across the room
and i pity you tiffany tumbles i pity
you
because you don't think you're real
until a man in a lab coat signs a
prescription pad
and i can't imagine what it must be like
to have so little confidence in your own
reality okay well don't patronize me i'm
just trying to understand
tiffany tumbles why you think being
transgender is all about
hating yourself and hating your body why
can't trans identity be
joyful and celebratory now you don't
have to hate yourself or hate your body
but you do have to have dysphoria and if
you tell people otherwise
you're just misleading them i want to
heal the rift inside your heart
tiffany tumbles would you please join me
in
saying a prayer for your wellness
actually i would strongly prefer if you
would stay away from any of my rifts o
goddess of light please shield and
protect tiffany against the ravages
of inner strife enclose her in your
loving arms
and cleanse her of all condemnation and
internalized transphobia
i entreat you o great mother faith
tiffany in
inner peace acceptance and self-care and
rid her of her toxic cis-normative true
scum ways
amen are we done here i don't think i
can make it through any more readings
from the sjw prayer book
tiffany why are you rejecting the love i
am trying to deliver unto you because
i'm grossed out by you
that's why okay then well namaste
[ __ ] look why don't we all take a step
back
and take a moment just to honor our
heroes in uniform and
let them know how much we appreciate
their service
god i love the troops thinking about the
troops makes me wet
it makes me [ __ ] semper fi boys what
i think i'm starting to wrap my head
around this tiffany your
transsexualism i have to say i don't
love it
but you do seem to at least be aware
that you have some kind of mental
disorder so
i'll give you that whereas baltimore
you're what making some kind of
statement if my existence is a statement
i think that says more about society
than it says about me
jackie what you have to understand is
there have been transsexuals around for
a long time
i've talked to 80 year old transsexuals
and they agree with me that all this
genderqueer
[ __ ] it's just a trend it's a fact
but is it for thousands of years there
have been third gender groups across
human cultures there's the hedra of
india
the two-spirit people among native
americans whereas
binary transsexualism is a medical
construct of the 20th century
gender dysphoria wasn't even a
recognized medical condition until 2013
meaning that tumblr is twice as old
as the first gender dysphoria diagnosis
so perhaps it is you tiffany tumbles
and not i who is following a trend
wow that just blew my mind the tables
are turned [ __ ]
tiffany could you explain to me why you
decided to become a transtrender
he's not native american though they
they you know it's kind of hard not to
call you he when you have a [ __ ]
beard
if you were actually trans and you
actually had dysphoria then you wouldn't
be comfortable with that your honor
in my defense it is a glitter beard okay
well that's very 2019 very gender very
they
but what it isn't is two spirit look the
sjws don't even agree with this they
think it's racist
white people have two genders pick one
and sit down dude
yeah that's a good point two genders two
genders attack helicopter
it's ma'am okay well now you're just
generally there's only two genders
[Music]
i don't have dysphoria the one thing
you'll always have to deal with in life
is [ __ ] it's hard to be yourself
but it's worth it let's be ourselves
let's totally be ourselves oh right
that's enough of this
you know as a biological female
i honestly don't understand any of this
[ __ ] okay
that was a hard tea now does my husband
sometimes wear panties around the house
and ask me to call him mommy's little
[ __ ]
well sure but that is a matter between
her
and the lord let's not think about it
too much
anyway tiffany my brain has an easier
time processing you than
whatever is going on over here so
congratulations you're the winner
that was some excellent free speech okay
great so in conclusion transtrenders
are real and probably dangerous make
sure to protect your children
as for how many genders there are you
know i'm going to take the centrist
route and say
2 and a half alright that's our show
this has been the freedom report where
the debate
never stops except when the show's over
get out the girl can't help it she's a
libra
behold the non-binary lamb who was
despised and rejected
they gave their cheek to them that
mocked their beard and did knock their
face from shame
but hello tiffany the persecutrix
trainier than thou a shady queen came
next
upon her friend justine and sought her a
council
god damn it justine i just can't with
these trenders anymore
i simply cannot you know you can just
text me here and i'll come
open the door okay seems a little formal
ugh feel a great hand cute
justine you look like absolute [ __ ] what
happened did the cat girl finally beat
you up
no i just look i slept in my makeup okay
leave me alone i've been having a
difficult time are we serving a little
depression moment
jesus well don't leave me out i saw you
on the freedom report today
okay girl can we talk about ladybird
baltimore maryland oh
add that one to the crazy trendy hall of
fame really
you're happy with the way that went you
feel good about that
you feel good about yourself right now
well why wouldn't i
tiffany there is nothing more sad and
pathetic
and desperate and low in this world than
a tran
who thinks she's better than other trans
it's like a drunk feeling superior to a
junkie
you seem to think that you're queen of
the world because you're hanging onto
societal acceptance
by two fingers instead of one well
you're not [ __ ]
you're just an insecure frightened
little queer who's determined to use the
one ounce of power you have
to tread other people down and if i'm
being honest
i don't find that very admirable
your eyelashes coming unglued
[Music]
my life is coming unclude
look it's not like i'm coming after
[ __ ] you just can't afford to
transition or don't have the social
support
it's not like baltimore's doing
everything he can to pass
and people just treat him like a freak
for no reason hey
it's they are we really saying they now
in private yes we are so get used to it
my name is justine i think misgendering
is toxic because i care about people's
feelings
ugh i always forget that you're like
actually an sjw
i always forget that you're actually an
[ __ ] why do i even hang out with you
oh because you hate yourself and you
have to believe there's hope for me
because if there's hope for me there
might be hope for you
wow you're developing self-consciousness
where'd you learn that trick
gigi tiffany
have you ever been bullied oh let's see
let me think
oh only k-12 nine hours a day but you
don't see me going on talk shows to play
the victim no i see you going on talk
shows to play the bully
i think you grew up getting bullied for
being a [ __ ] till you started passing
as a woman
and then you got a little taste of
normal and now you want to be the one
who bashes the queers
bash them if anything i'm the one
defending trans people from
appropriation and misrepresentation by
these trenders
you said on air that baltimore grosses
you out
do you really expect me to believe that
your motivations here have
nothing to do with your own
self-loathing how could it be
self-loathing when baltimore is
nothing like me okay then it's just
bigotry that's even worse
oh it's not bigotry look i shouldn't
have said gross doubt i'll give you that
but he does they do make me
uncomfortable
and why do you think that is ugh i got
secondhand dysphoria looking at someone
so
burgeoning ugh it makes me want to down
a bottle of hormones make sure i never
look like that [ __ ] secondhand
dysphoria what is that
you know when you look at a tree and you
just clock everything
and you feel like sympathetic vibrations
of dysphoria
yeah i do know what you're talking about
and i'll tell you why it happens
when you're early in your transition and
you're doing everything you can to pass
you develop a really sophisticated eye
for every little thing that makes you
clockable
then you turn that sophisticated eye
onto
other trans people and you project your
dysphoria onto them i buy that
yeah well that is absolutely not a valid
reason to please other trans people's
presentation
secondhand dysphoria is not valid the
fact that you project
your dysphoria onto other people is your
problem
and your problem alone and you need to
deal with that issue in private girl not
on a [ __ ] talk show
yeah you're probably right about that
but it still doesn't make baltimore
maryland any more valid
tiffany let's be pragmatic about this
suppose everything you're saying is true
suppose the only real trans people are
dysphoric binary transgender people
transsexuals every time you say the word
transsexual i feel like it's 1978.
are you 80 years old i guess you could
say i'm not the trendiest person
look suppose you're right and everyone
who doesn't meet your definition of a
transsexual
is some kind of confused trend follower
even if that were true
and to be clear it isn't what you're
doing harms
even the trans people you think are
valid because virtually every trans
person goes through a period of being
confused about their gender
and of having non-conforming expression
and you're going around enforcing a
stigma against that
didn't you ever have doubts about your
gender weren't you ever androgynous
oh yeah i mean i was never that
burgeoning but
i had my little cringier being a
non-binary sjw
and one of the great things about
non-binary identities is they give trans
people the conceptual space to exist
even when neither gender really fits
them whether that's for their entire
life or just for a couple months
hasn't it occurred to you that being
shamed and berated for being a trender
during your exploration year might not
have been the most helpful thing
not really i have dysphoria so if anyone
called me a trender i'd eventually prove
them wrong
that's all i'm saying if you're not a
trender then transition
prove me wrong the stigma you perpetuate
against gender confusion and
experimentation
keeps trans people in the closet and
delays transition
it alienates baby trans from the
community that should be welcoming them
instead of publicly humiliating them and
when you appoint yourself the public
decider of whomsed is really trans
the torquemada of the trender
inquisition you're
terrorizing a lot of people who are
genuinely trying to figure themselves
out
okay but then how do we decide which
trainees are valid
we don't but this is where i'm losing
you because transtrenders are absolutely
a thing
like undeniably i've talked to people
who've literally told me they used to be
trans trenders
so some people question their gender but
end up deciding they're not really trans
there is nothing wrong with that and
those people still aren't being helped
by
public shaming well maybe they wouldn't
be confused in the first place if sjws
weren't going around
telling people they don't need dysphoria
to be trans you know it's one thing if
teenage girls want to dye their hair
pink and call themselves demi boys for
most of sophomore year
but some of these kids are actually
going to medically transition and
soon we're going to have an epidemic of
detransitioners on our hands
and there's going to be turfs publishing
i told you so op-eds in every major
newspaper
now maybe you think that's worth it just
to make sure no one ever feels
invalidated for any reason
but i think that's highly irresponsible
look
if you're so worried about people
feeling pressured to medically
transition
then what you should be doing is working
to make the trans community
as inclusive and welcoming as possible
to gender non-conforming people
and non-binary people and people who are
questioning and trans people who don't
medically transition
but instead you're doing the exact
opposite
you're telling everyone that medical
transition is the only way to be valid
and if anything is pressuring people to
medically transition
it's that justine i think you're a good
person
maybe too good and that's why you're
trying to have compassion for everyone
but at some point you have to protect
yourself we live in a world of jackie
jackson's who don't understand trans
people
and don't think we're real so we need to
have an explanation of what it is to be
trans that's based on facts
and not feelings and the most factual
explanation
is transmedicalism which is the idea
that transsexualism
is a diagnosable mental disorder called
gender dysphoria
there's science to back this up it's
accepted by medical professionals
and it clearly explains why we are valid
unlike
rachel dolezal and snowflake gender
teenagers and people who identify as
cats
okay i see the appeal but i don't think
transmedicalism is as validating as you
think it is
why not i'll put it bluntly why does
having gender dysphoria make you a woman
because gender dysphoria means i have a
female brain
no it doesn't i'm sorry to tell you but
the science does not say what you think
it says
there may be neurological causes of
gender dysphoria
but at the end of the day all dysphoria
is is discomfort in a male body or a
male social role or however you want to
put it
and wanting to be a woman is not the
same thing
as being a woman not by any means
girl where are you going with this what
is this are you becoming a turf no i
just don't think your theory
actually validates our womanhood well if
you're right
that's a real problem because we need to
have reason
and science and logic and facts on our
side so that we can explain to society
that we are valid and that we are real
otherwise
bad things well maybe there's a better
theory well
okay socrates let's hear it then the way
i see it
gender is either psychological or
biological
or social now my friend tabby the cat
girl
she thinks it's all psychological that
it's just identity
that whatever you think about your own
gender is true and that makes me
really uncomfortable because then what's
the difference between identifying as a
woman
and identifying as a norwegian forest
cat it's a difference that tabby herself
seems not to have much of a grip on girl
that's literally what i've been trying
to tell you about trans trenders this
entire time just let me finish
if gender is strictly biological then
that's game over for trans people
unless you make some kind of wrong brain
in the wrong body argument but i told
you i'm not buying that
so that leaves gender as a social
construct are you gonna try to make me
read judith butler again i'll summarize
it
gender is a series of gestures it's
called performativity
it's the way you dress it's the way you
speak it's the way you act
it's the way you relate to other people
through transitioning
we habituate to the gestures of
womanhood and socially
that makes us women regardless of
biology or psychology
checkmate transphobe
okay the problem with that is that it's
both too exclusionary
and too inclusive it excludes a lot of
trans people who can't transition for
circumstantial reasons
but whose dysphoria is very real and it
includes
every transtrender drag queen fetishist
and two-bit cross-dressing comedian in a
dinal wig
well do you really believe that a man
who plays a woman on stage becomes
just as much of a woman as you and me
yes [ __ ] no you don't yeah you're right
i'm full of [ __ ] i know you are because
you're an sjw
and sjws hate performativity theory
almost as much as they hate me well they
only hate it because they don't
understand it
they think it invalidates non-binary
identities but in fact is the most
rational way to explain non-binary
identities how can you perform
a non-binary identity simple you learn
the rules so you can break them
wearing a beard and a dress communicates
ambiguity
even the gesture of declaring i am
neither a man or a woman
is a speech act that removes the speaker
from the semantics girl shut up
this is too much philosophizing i can't
stand it anymore
why don't you tell me what's really
going on with you why do you look like
you've been in a k-hole for a week
why are you suddenly so obsessed with
white knighting for non-binary people
because i am non-binary no you're not
what are you talking about i just feel
like
since i started transitioning i've been
trying so hard to fit in
and to perform my gender and to pass and
to just be normal
but i can't do it anymore i just cannot
make it work
i feel like an actor i feel like a
zombie like i'm
going through the motions of this new
general that's supposed to liberate me
but that's somehow just as empty as the
old one
because i'm just not normal tiffany i'm
a freak
and i'm always going to be a freak
justine you're not non-binary you're gay
and everyone can see this except you oh
come on
i'm not i'm not gay
justine was extremely gay
protest though there simply is no
stopping
us i love cat girls
i hate talent girls but i also love them
oh abominable fate okay
so i'm a little bit gay right and you
don't know how to reconcile your
attraction to women with your desire to
reform your gender
that's why you feel this dissonance yeah
i guess that's basically it well it
really shouldn't be that hard girl
you already came out as a woman just
blurted out say
hello world my name is justine and i
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a very cis-normative
way to
say it hello world my name is justine
and
i a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh i feel like a man when
i say it
yeah well you should probably buy a
pickup truck then get some of those mud
flaps on the back with the little sexy
ladies on them and
you may as well change your name back to
justin okay well
that's just uncalled for crow i don't
know what to say except i told you so
sexuality is just like gender identity
it is not a performance it's not a trend
it's not a choice
it's just part of who you are and
there's nothing you can do to change it
i guess you're right i guess my theory
sucks it sucks
so [ __ ] hard but the good news is you
can unclench your [ __ ] now and do
whatever you want because you're still a
woman whether you're performing a
stereotype or not
so run free justine go top assist woman
bang a gay guy wear some oversized
flannel
do whatever you want wow yeah i guess i
guess that is pretty liberating
yeah thank god for transmedicalism right
oh
except not because you just destroyed
transmedicalism with facts and logic
so we have no theory we have no theory
justine
what do we do now how do we prove we're
valid well just do what every trans
woman has done since the beginning of
time
go out and [ __ ] the most brutally
heterosexual man you can find and
be validated and come oh honey i have
and i will
but that's not going to convince anyone
but me it's not a proof
some theory well maybe we don't need a
theory
maybe we don't need to prove anything
bad things just seen
bad things well do we have a theory
about why people are gay
no they just are the only reason we even
feel like we need a theory about trans
people
is that society is so unaccepting of us
that it's constantly demanding we
justify our own reality okay
so what am i supposed to tell jackie
jackson then what am i supposed to tell
the turfs
that i'm a woman because reasons no not
even because
reasons just because you are so it's
what a leap of faith
oh great i'm sure that's going to
convince all the rational skeptics
justine it makes us sound completely
delusional well
tiffany delusion is what separates us
from the animals
who do you think built the pyramids in
the cathedrals clearly not people with a
perfectly rational worldview
but what do you care anyway aren't you
the one who thinks being trans is a
mental disorder well i wouldn't describe
it as the height of sanity
but i would prefer to think that my
whole life and identity is based on
something i can rationally explain
well what are we tiffany men isn't the
single most obnoxious thing about men
that they think they have to wrap up the
entire world in a little rational box
maybe the most important things in life
can't be logically proved
can you logically prove that you love
your own children
no and the attempt to prove it is as
degrading as it is futile
maybe gender identity is one of those
things okay
but then how do i prove i'm more valid
than baltimore maryland and the star
genders
and the cat people well maybe we should
stop getting so caught up in proving our
validity to ourselves
that we end up being horribly cruel to
other people what if we just accept all
the freaks of the world
at the end of the day maybe it's just
not as important to have logical proofs
as it is to be empathetic and
open-minded and compassionate
kumbaya my lord kumbaya
[Music]
here it comes i love you
okay well i'm going to get going now i
have a
important date tonight drinking vodka
cranberries and reading youtube comments
by myself
so i really better go do that but
uh good luck with your new life as a
male lesbian who [ __ ] cats
oh are you upset just go
i'm sorry
i hate this [ __ ] but
god she's a yum yum
[Music]
i am nothing like that for i
am truth i am light i am in
capitalism and everything i tweet is
woke
most importantly i love myself
i love myself so much it makes me wet it
makes me
cup praise beyond to me hallelujah
like comment subscribe
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you